let's get into orience questions I
encourage you to submit a question to
the show first one today is from arya
who said hey david have advertisers ever
contacted you to tell you that they
don't like your position on an issue or
that they want you to change your
position on a political issue and how
did you react you know I'm glad to say
the answer is no we've never had a
situation where an advertiser says we
will advertise with you if you change
your position on this issue or we're
gonna pull ad money
if David doesn't say X Y or Z and in
fact I don't even have contact with the
advertisers in the early days I did but
now that we have associate producer and
I guess we would call him marketing
representative I don't even know how to
drive him Noah Ferguson I don't even
talk to the advertisers period and Pat
doesn't talk to the advertisers Noah
deals with the advertisers and we
basically get notified about a new
advertiser coming on and when they're
advertising and what they're doing and I
just don't even have contact with
advertisers except for you know a very
specific situation we're trying to think
what would even be a situation where I
have a contact with an advertiser I
don't even know but no there's not even
we don't even really have a mechanism
for advertisers to talk to me directly
they just work with Noah and I wouldn't
do that and we've had situations where
advertisers are not an obvious fit
because of some political position and
we could sort of try to push a deal and
we'll just say it just doesn't seem like
a good fit for us
yeah we're certainly not going to
advertise for some defense contractor or
a pharmaceutical company nor would they
want to advertise on our program anyway
we usually try to avoid I mean we always
try to avoid those conflicts of
interests like if we have you know many
of our advertisers are like a mattress
company yeah or someone who sells
audiobooks like there's no clear I don't
see how our reporting and our
perspective could you know be issues
that are important to them right like
yeah I don't know I mean I'm sure
there's like always some regulatory
thing that companies could be impacted
with that we were not really
aware of in some way and we might be
lobbying against some law that we don't
relive but why would they then there's
the question of even if we are at odds
with an advertiser on some particular
issue would they really want to change
our position if we're bringing an
audience to their product or service and
the ad relationship is working well so I
think that even if there were conflicts
of that kind with advertisers it's not
even clear that they benefit by us
saying something different I think they
would be more likely to just pull their
future ads yeah than they would to tell
us to change our opinion about something
right I have an understanding of how
their world works and that's just not
how it works I tend to agree yeah so
Aria no the answer is advertisers have
not ever asked me to say or not say any
particular thing and we wouldn't do it
and we would try to not even bring on an
advertiser that we would even remotely
suspect would want to do that at some
point